hey leute herzlich willkommen zur
sechsten folge von minecraft maus die
hälfte ist geschafft wobei das heißt die
hälfte ist geschafft leider ist die
hälfte geschafft oder luca die hälfte
ist vorbei leider so wie gesagt wir
hatten heute den ganzen tag durch damit
minecraft muss wirklich cool wird für
euch opengl treiber ist gecrasht ich
muss mal kurz neustarten was man heute
vor luca wie lautete haben muss müssen
wir erst mal ganz kurz sagen was wir
nach der letzten folge ist uns
aufgefallen dass wir tatsächlich sehr
sehr viel an diesem haus noch machen
mussten so wie wir es uns vorgestellt
haben im saß noch nicht zu beginn aus
deswegen haben wir jetzt aufs spiel noch
ein bisschen weiter gebaut ihr seht
wahrscheinlich schon in unseren inventar
gibt es ein paar änderungen ich hab zum
beispiel apple dazu bekommen wir haben
einfach noch sehr viel von diesen wo
hast du die hergeholt diese birken du
meinst die dunkelbier die birken gewahrt
ich zeig dir die helfen da vorne wo ich
wo ich letzte folge auch war hier vorne
siehst du das sehr große becken wird die
hälfte fehlt schon wir machen heute
einfach noch ein bisschen weiter am haus
und es wird ziemlich schwierig und ich
glaube luca konnte ich sagen warum weil
die challenge für heute ist mal wieder
die absolute krise die challenge heute
hat wieder etwas mit minecraft zu tun
bzw das erste mal und zwar darf ich
bestimmen wenn ich beispielsweise sage
okay ab jetzt dann muss max eine minute
lang seine hände über kreuz packen auf
die tastatur das heißt die rechte hand
mit der rechner muss rwe für die
bedienung mit der linken muss er die
maus bedienen können dass er
beispielsweise einfach mal zu hause
mitmachen also wenn ihr jetzt gerade am
pc sein und nebenbei surft oder
minecraft studie da keine ahnung was
immer wenn ich sage jetzt müsst ihr die
hände quasi vertraut schon das ist so
schwierig so wir bauen jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen am haus weiter luca wenn wir
das dach noch fertig machen würde ich
sagen
schließen wir erstmal das projekt
hausbau komplett ab oder und danach so
ein bisschen weiter rumlaufen mainz
ja genau dadurch dass auf diese zehn
folgen sag ich mal um selber begrenzt
haben ist es ja auch so dass wir uns
dazu gezwungen haben jetzt nicht nur uns
ist wird es gerade nacht ist wird nacht
ok ab in die kisten würde ich sagen
der eingang der stört mich noch
irgendwie so ein bisschen da damit so
treppen reingeht klar nehme ich ich ich
finde auch also vor allem dass ich hatte
der kabel lockerten abgebaut
wie das aussieht von außen gehen wir
raus von außen sieht das so geil aus
oder könnt man mega geil so fackeln hin
packen uns
das sieht echt cool aus aber von drinnen
sieht es einfach nur noch scheiße aus
oder kann man das irgendwie doch wenn
man so macht geht's ja genau machen wir
das einfach so ist schon wieder opengl
ich muss jetzt mal probieren mit shader
raus wenn das die ganze zeit jetzt
abstürzt hat ja nicht wirklich sinn
vielleicht sind jetzt manche leute die
den shader voll hätten jetzt mega froh
weil er endlich aus ist er es gibt ja
verschiedene meinungen viele sagen ja
der shader model macht es viel zu dunkel
und so ich selber mag den shader ich
habe jetzt auch heute zum glück noch
keine probleme damit gehabt aber ich
mein lieber das findet vernünftige
spielerfahrungen haben als das der
shader die ganzen ruhm brachte marc
zimmer vom server fliegt aber wie wollen
wir das machen jetzt mit dem dach
einfach rüber einfach über bauen wir mit
welchem material einfach hier so mit dem
material
bevor wir jetzt hier das dingens bauen
was ist auch eine minute am handy ihr
seht schon leute einmal ein minuten
start ab jetzt es läuft runter wenn das
fertig ist werde ich nicht melden dann
werdet ihr einen ton hören aber max muss
jetzt tatsächlich so rumlaufen ist es so
es ist einfach nicht nur schwierig
sondern einfach so eine ungesunde
bewegung irgendwie man dehnt sich so
komplett durch also ihr seht dass ihr an
meinen händen da ja das ist einfach nur
noch den es ist schwer luca läuft nur
noch 16 sekunden also es geht relativ
schnell um tatsächlich das gut
wir suchen jetzt auch gerade in der nähe
hier eine
höhle würde ich sagen aber ich kann
nicht okay doch ich habe den knopf
gefunden
okay ist ich will mich nicht alles
täuscht haben wir wirklich direkt unter
dem berg der höhle als wenn ich weiß
nicht wie tief die geht aber das schon
mal so ein höhlensystem als wenn junge
wie geil ist das denn hier geht es nicht
weil dort unter unserem direkt runter
das ist hammer geil aber okay das freut
mich an mega light mal kurz sebastian
kommt gerade rein diesem film ja wie
minecraft marge auf wird produzieren
gerade vor bis jetzt dabei sein
was machst du so was passiert bei euch
er hat mir einfach gerade eine komplette
hand ins gesicht gesetzt
jorge fans warten weiter auf name alter
der kopfhörer leute ich habe keine
ahnung was das gerade war mein linkes
auge brennen von sebastian also mein
bruder das gerade gemacht hat hat den
ganzen tag überlegt was er für ein video
machen kann und anscheinend ist es
einfach ein prank in meiner aufnahme
geworden vielen dank dafür
das video ist auf jeden fall auf seinem
kanal schon online ihr könnt mal dahin
zurückgehen und das euch rein ziehen
dann wisst ihr jetzt auch zu welchem
zeitpunkt wir ca aufheben lädt das
nämlich sofort hoch und das ist echt
lange her gewesen bemühe mich erstmal
ein feld zu machen ich habe noch ein
bisschen knochenmehl hast du auch
welches ich habe wenn schon oben in der
kiste also ich habe jetzt hier meinem
inventar gar nichts aber ich würde sagen
erst mal max eine minute ab jetzt aber
ihre hände über 90 max ist muss leider
sagen jetzt denkt wahrscheinlich ja die
faken das immer so dieses online macht
das nicht oder so ist ist einfach
wirklich die hölle wenn man gerade so
ein bisschen produktiv sein will
nein wenn ich mich jetzt anreiz ich habe
keine chance es gibt nur bestrafen das
war kämpfen also ohne schwer damit nur
händen okay du mich einfach trotzdem
besser
neben luca du hast timer gestellten
dateien allerdings abgelaufen schneller
wenn du mir erlaubt meine hand zu
entspiegeln ich werde jetzt mal in ruhe
bei uns auf den berg locken ja man
dieses doofe nun packt einfach die ganze
zeit in die blöcke rein und man meint
den hund es besser wenn du hier oben ist
übrigens alle kuhne bei uns oben
hier ist ihr einfach hoch gelaufen er
warte man dann wohl ich lieber ne zweite
kuh
ich mache jetzt mal erst mal so eine
kleine farm hin so ein bisschen
zumindest dafür brauchen jetzt erst mal
eine hose oder haben wir die hohe umfang
anzupacken
20 für meine weizenkörner hin in die
ecken hallo scharf hast du weizen max
der ich kann schnell welchen machen
willst machen du musst mir zu finden
haye findet man nicht lokal gesehen und
staune also diese die kölner die beizen
können aber nicht also mir kriegen wir
jetzt hier raus gibt mir einen weizen
luca bitte dann kann ich uns natürlich
gut
ich habe mir das zubrot gemacht und ab
das gegessen was okay ist nicht so
schlimm
dann mache ich nur mal ein neues weiß um
dessen märz weitere holen kann weißt du
einfach mal eine ansage machen und sagen
nächste woche nächste folge finden wir
bei dir diamanten diamanten das wäre
halt krass aber ich mein notfall so
nehmen wir halt eine halbe stunde auf
und finden dann wirklich welche okay ja
das was ich jetzt gerade mache ist ich
mache gerade unser dach jetzt endlich
mal zu ende das solltest du einfach
machen
das heißt wir bräuchten auch noch
schwarz eichen schwarz eichen haben wir
direkt im wald aber auch schon gut dabei
ich berate gerade noch 26 glas das heißt
wenn wir nach der folge vielleicht auch
spielen das dach fertig machen dann
können wir meiner folge uns auf jeden
fall darum widmen die das irgendwie zu
holen ok planänderung ich bringe es ein
schaf mit tricks ist ein schaf mit her
doch noch
kommt koch walter
sie wollte direkt self merck machen
wusste jetzt ja andere brunhilde
verdammt noch mal
ich werde doch mal ein er sieht die alle
lebensmüde sie geht hier voller der ich
will sie einsperren nur sobald ich in
die nähe von einem zaun kommen laufen
die mir nicht mehr nach bruni boni kommt
sie nicht wirklich bruni würde ich ja
original laufen
du bleibst alles drin wetter und die
zweite kommt zugleich also wir werden
jetzt mal wenig wert auf artgerechte
tierhaltung legen weil uns geht es jetzt
erst mal ums überleben wie finde ich den
fortschritt in diesem raum hier überall
gut also wirklich gut
respektlos denkt ihre ich schieb die
jetzt einfach die sind einfach so blöd
die fischer die machen nie was sie
sollen das versteh mich nicht falsch
wb pic bierbaum berührt wie raus aus der
tür mit dir und ich hab so angst dass
die jetzt direkt abbauen wird
ich bin sehr zufrieden mit unserem
eingangsbereich dafür dass ich so übel
ist minecraft leider eigentlich bin
überhaupt nicht bauen kann bin ich sehr
zufrieden luca sagt ich bin der übelste
minecraft leyen macht seit vier oder
fünf jahren minecraft hilfe ihres weiter
ja aber ich weiß noch nicht wirklich gut
im bau oder so ich weiß also unnütze
scheiße ja klar
heute sagen wie viele blöcke bis zum
himmel sind oder sonstwie 44 mio hast du
noch ein bisschen weißen übrig dann
können wir das bruni und ihrer schwester
da warte ich aber ich finde es hier
üblich findet johanna geworden ich
wollte hier oben jetzt noch glas
zurückstecken
wow ich habe den eindruck dass hier oben
ist superschön alter wir können
eigentlich auch das dach einfach offen
lassen
das wollte ich mit glas mit sowie in
seiner kirche wo ich das machen
ein bisschen bei kirche geben glas leid
aber die haben so am rand immer diese
nennt man die genau die haben einen
besonderen namen diese fans ich weiß was
du meinst diese fenster diese religiösen
fenster dort mit den ganzen malereien
keine ahnung was ich wähle ich weiß
nicht was ihr nicht soll ich machen will
ist das eine gute idee aber du kannst
keine bunten vorbei doch du kannst
theoretisch schon bunte fenster machen
ja aber ich wollte jetzt keine bunten da
habe ich gar nicht gedacht sondern ich
wollte es jetzt einfach so ein bisschen
machen warte ich zeig dir gleich mal
nichts vorhabe
doch ich weiß wie du meinst okay das ist
das eine echt gute idee leute ich handle
ich glaube so langsam aber sicher wir
haben zwar einen geist geschafft diese
folge aber ich würde auch gekränkt und
sonst was
da kann das schon mal vorkommen was ich
sagen wollte ich glaube ich werde jetzt
mal diese folge beenden auch wenn es
halt einfach ich finde einfach echt das
macht fun nächste folge gibt es bei luca
auf dem kanal
wir machen jetzt erst mal off screen
noch ein bisschen weiter damit dass in
der nächsten folge richtig spannend wird
okay dann macht's mal gut leute wie sie
uns beim nächsten mal wieder und ciao
[Musik]